(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] How are you?
- Look at you in New York.
- You look incredible, you're glowing.
Do you love New York,
do you love being here?
- I'm only really ever
here when I do a show.
So I'll live here for months on end.
- Yeah, that's living here though.
- But it's only sort of every 10 years
that I end up on Broadway.
- But when I'm here, I love it.
- Yeah, did you grow up doing theater?
Is that why you love it so much?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I think I was 28 before
I had a television audition.
It was all theater through
my teens and my twenties.
- I love hearing that though, for actors
that are still like pushing
and they're like, man, I'm 28.
Like, I haven't hit how I want to yet.
Like I love hearing that,
and you're this huge TV star.
You just never know like, timing.
- And back then sort of, I was hitting,
I was just getting into
television in my about to be 30
and it was suddenly too old.
- Yeah.
- I was playing dads
in my first-
- Yeah, so it's awesome.
I heard that you got to do
this and I've never seen
Elton John live and I'm so jealous.
But you got to go to his-
- You haven't?
- [Kelly] I haven't.
- That's crazy.
- I was poor growing up, man.
And then by the time I
made money, I'm so busy.
I only catch shows like when I can.
But Elton is incredible.
And I heard that you
were at his final concert
here in North America.
- Well, so one of my,
a story I love to tell
when I was doing theater in high school,
I was doing a production
of Godspell in 11th grade.
And one of my co-stars was David Furnish,
who is now Elton John's husband.
So we've had a relationship
through our lives
and I've had one with Elton
that see, I don't know,
10, 12 times I've seen
Elton over the years.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, you lucky man.
- I know, it's so great.
It's also allowed for
some crazy friendships,
like the people I got to meet
through that period of time.
'Cause you know, a lot of
actors look up to other actors.
I was just in awe of musicians always.
I, when I was 15, I just wanted to be you.
I wanted to be a rock star.
I wanted to do what you do.
- That's so funny
'cause my favorites are
actors, that sing, but yeah.
- We're shallow and empty.
- [Kelly] No!
- I wouldn't worry about it.
But so I wanted, so I loved
Elton and I got to meet
Bernie Taupin who writes
all of Elton's lyrics
and we became friends through the years.
- Great writer.
- And I wanted to show
this, so I was invited.
- [Kelly] You recreated it.
- Yeah yeah, so this is Bernie
Taupin's 70th birthday party.
There's Bernie, Elton,
Alice Cooper, and me.
And I based this photograph
on this photograph,
which is from 1972, I think.
Alice Cooper,
- [Kelly] You needed to undo
your shirt a little bit more.
Give some more chest hair.
- Do you recognize who that is?
Between Alice and Elton is Paul Lynde
from the "Hollywood Squares".
So I'm Paul Lynde in
2000, whatever that was
- Next time just gold
chain, more chest hair.
- Gold chain, yeah.
- Yes, yeah.
- So I mean, when I'm 15 I'm in my bedroom
pretending to be Alice Cooper.
Like, that was how I became an actor
was wanting to be a rock star.
- Isn't it funny though,
I find that the people,
'cause I met him years ago, Alice.
And he was so nice, like so sweet.
And he is this huge rock
star with goth makeup
and all this stuff.
I was like, I was kind
of afraid to meet him,
but he's so nice.
- He's so nice, and it's all a character.
It's a character that I still
do at Halloween occasionally.
- Yeah, well, it's a
great one, it's a classic.
So what did you listen to music as a kid?
You listened to Alice?
- It was that, Queen was my big one.
- [Kelly] Oh, Freddie Mercury.
- And my father loved
when I'd put on, you know,
tights in my bedroom and
(audience laughing)
I'd go downstairs to get
something from the kitchen.
He was like, "You stay in
your room in those things!"
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- But yeah, that's who I
wanted to be very much.
- By the way, you are my son,
My seven year old son is
like, he looks like a little,
it's like Harry Styles
is that generation now.
'Cause he, his wardrobe is so
eclectic and I love it that
Harry is like a
representative for him because
he is also talented, but
he also dresses so fun
and eccentric, you know, a bit.
And my son my feels
comfortable and he's seven
and that's so awesome because, you know,
sometimes they're always
like, boys can't do that.
And I always look at him, I'm like,
boys can do anything they want, you know?
- And my my son's 21 in
college and this is the time
to be in college is just
the experimentation.
- Yeah, you never know.
Well, what was your first concert?
Very first.
- I'd love to say that it was Queen,
but that was really my second in 78.
My first was ELO and
Meatloaf opened for them.
- I actually loved Meatloaf.
- I know.
- Yes.
♪ I would do anything ♪
I loved it, it was very operatic, yeah.
Well that first album wasn't even out yet.
That's "Paradise by the Dashboard Light"
and all that stuff hadn't really dropped,
which is why they were an opening band,
but they were an opening band
in front of 70,000 people.
- Oh my gosh.
- And there's, you know,
he's little, he's that big on the stage,
but that album, wow.
- Oh my gosh, that's
a great first concert.
I can't, I can't even remember.
Mine was either Aerosmith or Celine Dion,
which are very different.
Very passionate, both, but yeah,
- I saw Aerosmith too in like
70, I think it was 78, 79.
- Oh man, that changed my,
we were gonna get married, yeah.
- You and Steven?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was, yeah.
- Was he aware of it?
- No, but he would love me.
- Of course he would.
- Yeah, no, I went to the
concert and I just love
that feeling that you get inspired people.
That's how I get by actors by the way
because it's such a
different world for me.
- Right.
- But I get that with
certain musicians as well.
And just seeing him, you
know, (mimicking Steven Tyler)
with the fan and everything.
I just, yeah, I would
pretend I was Steven Tyler.
- That whole (indistinct)
thing that he used to,
I mean, he can still do it, but wow.
What he was doing in '73 was nuts.
- We did a photo shoot
though later in life.
And have you ever met
like one of your heroes?
And it was like, he was so
like, passionate that he was,
and my dream was for him
to go yaka yaka on my face,
but then when he was actually doing it,
I was like, ha ha ha.
I was like that's so funny, so funny.
And I just got so nervous.
I was overwhelmed with
passion deep inside.
So you're back on Broadway.
This is called "The Cottage", right?
- The Cottage, which is your
classic English sex farce.
- [Kelly] Okay, I'm in.
- It's hysterical, although it is,
oh there I am there.
(audience applauding)
- With that mustache.
- It's actually, it's
a new play written by
a young American woman.
But she just wanted to
write in the classic sort
of Noel Coward style.
So it's very, it's old fashioned,
but it's more from the female perspective.
It's like a feminist Noel Coward play.
But it's dirty as hell and-
- I would love it.
- You would love it, come see it.
- That's amazing.
Are you working with Laura Bell Bundy?
- [Eric] Yes.
- In it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I've run
into her a couple times.
- Laura Bell, she was
"Legally Blonde" the musical,
She was Tony nominated
and we are such a team
at the top of that show, I just
couldn't do it without her.
- It's so funny, now all I'm
seeing is Freddie Mercury
when I look at you right now.
You were literally talking and I was like,
listen, listen, listen.
And I can't, I was like, I can't,
like, now I'm just
picturing you in a movie
playing Freddie Mercury.
So I have a question.
So whenever an actor directs
you, like Jason Alexander
who directs this, is that different than
when it's not an actor?
Do they direct in a different way?
- Most actors love other actors
directing them for the most part.
I particularly love it 'cause
Jason and I are old friends,
not from NBC or whatever,
but from being dads at the same school.
- Oh, you have a shorthand.
- Yeah, yeah, and he directed
me in a production of
"The Fantastics" 11 years ago.
So we had a great shorthand.
And as a comedy legend,
I mean, I was just so,
it's so great, this is a
really freaking funny comedy.
- It's gotta be good too
to work with your friends.
Like that's what I am at the
age now to where I'm just like,
I just wanna work with
people I love to work with
and I just wanna do it, you know?
- At the same time I've always
loved meeting new people,
having new cast.
And I just gotta talk about
the cast of "The Cottage"
for one second.
They are all Broadway
pros, they are amazing.
And particularly my friend Dana Steingold,
who is a huge Kelly Clarkson fan.
- She has great taste.
- And I just said her name.
I just said it on television.
There you go, Dana, that's for you.
- So what is your favorite,
do you like acting
on stage like that, or
do you like acting on TV?
'Cause everybody always
asks me to act and I go,
I hate acting on TV or movie
anything like that I hate
because I don't like, I
like the constant stream of,
'cause I grew up in musical theater.
I like the stage acting better.
So what do you-
- Yeah, I mean, if I did it all the time,
perhaps I'd yearn for a little of it.
But I love being on stage.
I miss it and I'm hoping
to do a little bit more.
- Breaking up the monotony is cool though.
- Yeah, what was your musical
that you did in high school?
- I did a View, but the
one that I felt like
I finally was like, oh man,
I could do this for a living,
was I was "Seven Brides, Seven Brothers".
- Oh wow, okay.
- I was the lead in that.
So I was like, and it was double cast.
And so that-
- That's a lot of brides
and a lot of brothers.
- Yeah, yeah, well, there's a
political backstory to that,
that I'll save for off camera.
But no, and we only got one
show and we learned all of it.
So I was like, yeah,
the other cast got more.
But anyway, but it was
like incredible though
to that moment.
Do you remember that
moment you're on stage?
It was that I was singing
"One Man" in that,
and I just felt this
like overwhelming purpose
and it was magical.
- A hundred percent.
For me, that production of
"Godspell" I was talking about.
It wasn't even the evening performances
that we eventually did,
it was that assembly where
they bring the school together
and they do a thing for the
football team, whatever.
- We did that too.
- And now a theater class
is gonna do a song from
their new show "Godspell".
And it was that, it was being Jesus
in the rainbow suspenders
- Amongst your peers.
- Peers who had never much cared for me.
- Worship me!
But suddenly now it was
like, oh, okay, we get it.
And I was like, this is it.
- Wait, so speaking of
friends coming to a show,
I always tell people to never tell me
if someone comes to a show.
- [Eric] Oh really?
- Yeah, I hate knowing.
Do you like knowing?
- I like know, particularly
in a long run like this,
where you're doing the same show,
we've done it 110 times now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It helps me to see it through new eyes.
- Oh okay.
- I can get excited
because I know, so-and-so's out there,
and they're English, so
they'll hate my accent.
Or they're
- They're judgy.
- Or they're really judgy so
they'll hate the whole show.
- Oh man, I get, that makes me nerv,
I don't get nervous on stage,
but when I know that friends
or family or something,
I'm like, I don't wanna know, yeah.
- I don't know why it
gives me a little kick.
- So one time speaking of that though,
you actually surprised Sean Hayes, right?
Was it in Chicago?
- Yeah, so Sean, I dunno
if you got a chance
to see "Goodnight Oscar",
but he won the Tony for it.
- [Kelly] He's so talented.
- He's so incredible.
- [Kelly] and sweet.
- There's us together, but
he did it in Chicago first
and I knew he was doing
it, it was very low key.
This is like a year and a half ago.
But I flew in to see him and surprise him.
And I told him that night,
you're going to New York, right?
He said, yeah, hopefully, and I said,
"Yeah, you're gonna win the Tony."
- Oh my God, you're like,
Nostradamus, you predicted that.
- It was pretty clear,
he was pretty awesome.
- Yeah, he's so talented.
So have you ever had
huge mistakes on stage?
Because it's live, you can't stop.
- This show a lot, we have a
lot of prop things go wrong,
which leads to a lot of improv and funny.
But I haven't had terrible mistake.
The the one I always tell just
'cause it was the beginning of my career.
I had a sort of a standing over there
with a spear part in a
production of "King Lear"
giant production in Canada
at the Stratford Festival.
And one night I was just,
the fire in the center
of the stage and Lear is talking
and I know something bad's gonna happen.
I feel sick, I gotta go.
But I don't, I keep
waiting and I keep waiting.
It's a long scene, and
finally I turned to go
and I fainted dead away
and my helmet bounced
into the audience and my spear fell down.
Lear apparently went
(grunts) "Bear him, hence".
(audience laughing)
And so somebody picked me
up and then took me off
and I sort of came to at the stage door
and he hovered over me.
He'd finished the scene and
he came and he finished.
"Are you all right there boy?"
- Oh my God, he unplugged the whole thing.
That's amazing.
- Yes, and he went (grunts).
So note to self, don't faint.
- But that's what I love about stage.
That's what is, every night is different.
It could be the same play, same musical,
but these things happen and I love that.
The energy of that, I think
that's pretty magical.
- We've had a thing we do in this show
that I came up with in
rehearsal where I'm trying to
get rid of a damning brassiere
that is gonna give me away
and I throw it into the audience and-
- Like a rockstar.
You are Freddie Mercury.
- And then whatever I do with the person
that catches it is fun.
But once in a while the person
has thrown it back on stage,
which I love 'cause then
you can make stuff out.
- Yeah.
- It's pretty fun.
- Yeah, and then you're
like a comedian on stage.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
Well, I loved the side eye.
Well, let's take another break.
You can see Eric in "The
Cottage" on Broadway
at the Hayes Theater now
through October 29th.
And his podcast, "Just Jack
and Will" with Sean Hayes
and Eric McCormick is
available wherever you get your
podcasts or like to listen.